[Music]
it's an amazing feeling and I haven't
seen the film before so for me for me
I'm just genuinely excited all eyes were
on Michael B Jordan Monday night in LA
as he stepped out to celebrate the
premiere of his new Marvel superhero
film black panther you have a date
tonight
my friends I brought all my boys out my
mom dad sis they're best friends because
I did read where you said you were
technically single and I'm not what is
that that's like a little bit pregnant
what is total dating but you know
technically you found that one and I was
interviewed we're leaving love I waited
my entire life for this and Michael B
Jordan plays a villain I do I do
first time for that took it was fun to
be able to go into a different place and
take the chains off a little bit you
know you know and show a different side
you said you drew from like Heath
Ledger's inspiration when he was the
Joker to go to the place for for kill
manga right yeah in a sense of like you
know you know you want as an actor you
know you want certain performances them
that motivates you inspire and for me
Heath performance as a villain was so
captivating I couldn't stop watching and
I was like man okay if I can get into
that rare air you know of um of just a
character where people empathize but
still kind of understand but still are a
little taken back by it that I would
know it'll work out
[Music]